madame ellisabeth aimait y passer ses
journées le domaine lui a été offert par
son frère le roi Louis XV en
1783 une demeure et un jardin rien que
pour elle entretenu aujourd'hui par cinq
jardiniers c'est un domaine un petit peu
particulier hein vous pouvez savoir
qu'on est à 5 minutes du du grand
château de Versailles he c'est un parc
un petit peu untimiste on est dans un
écrin de verdure un petit peu un Pumon
vert au cœur de Versailles le parc la
français donc on est vraiment au temps
de Louis XIV on est sur le château de
versaill des choses très carrées très
strictes avec des bordures de Buie et là
on est quelque chose où on s'ouvre à la
nature he on arrive sur le concept de
Jean-Jacques Rousseau on prône le retour
à la nature et là on va retrouver des
perspectives on va trouver des allées
sinueuses
8 hectares de terrain que le public
pourra visiter avec les jardiniers une
manière de retracer l'histoire du jardin
remaniier au 19e siècle et de découvrir
des espaces insolites au détour du
tunnel de verre vous allez pouvoir
cheminer jusqu'à la grotte vous allez
pour voir derrière moi et cette grotte
un petit peu majestieuse c'est une
grotte qui été créé au tempant deisabeth
et dès que vous allez rentrer à
l'intérieur ça va être la sérénité le
calme parfait l'invitation à la
promenade est lancée il ne reste plus
qu'à y répondre